this is torture my tongue right now my
tongues like what do you want you want
to be clean or do you want to be a mess
I have coffee breath lot well in both
wear retainers you can like see the
smell coming out of this thing right now
I'm sho garlicky so used to kisi then
blow in my face this is actually how we
always kiss Oh somebody's bombing it up
like a bad smell or what I've been told
comes from after Tommy they move slowly
get down here gold I can Bartowski he's
a pretty good flosser lost luggage lost
the important ones that's great oh yeah
no not too bad that's awesome we did for
refreshing curiously strong means oh
just like eating [ __ ] so curiously
Queens actually hmm the kiss was like it
like neutralized all the food oh you can
smell the outside but it smells like you
ate Altoids on top of garlic bread and
chips
yeah this is like a thing that happens
hey you're gonna go to sell you later
know it bro bro in your mouth it's just
like a subtle hint of me
later with overwhelming garlic butter
pretty good that was really good
I'm gonna put this up my nose this tiny
strip can't do anything
it's burning my tongue up got stuck in
the river actually there yell that was
pretty good it works you're telling me
that one of these was better than me
brushing my teeth thoroughly brushing my
tongue and then flossing really was able
to like penetrate pungent Mallos the
other finish the TV you're running out
of your house you just wake some
Listerine spit it and then you're good
to go all about the hurting mmm so I
think what it is is like its back in
your throat oh that was good well I'm
just really getting used to the smell if
you're going to tip somebody after using
garlic you should wait about my six
months specialty they know that they're
supposed to brush this if you have to
pick one which is whooshes I hear our
breath is hearing their up and down
right I think God used to it I don't
think we need to go anywhere else from
there
good job thanks I can only have one of
those products which one would you
choose I would choose to walk no that's
not an honor and can I do more and drop
you can't if I give you options you
can't create another option well why us
that's not how we're all going to change
the rules